good morning John it's Sunday August 3rd
2014 and I love you your good brother
your good person and I'm lucky to have
you in my life I don't know where I'd be
without you or who I'd be without you
make me a better person you helped me
make better decisions you've been a good
person to look up to as a child and an
adult you just have good values even
though apparently you told bunch of
people the gun that I had a little bit
of a problem with showering when I was
true you could've kept that with
yourself if you're confused about why
I'm being so on ironically sappy right
now it's because today is Esther day in
2010 John asked Esther Earl a
nerdfighter who helped inspire the Fault
in Our Stars what she would like us as a
community to do on her birthday she said
she wanted it to be a day to celebrate
the kind of love that people have inside
of families and friendships not romantic
love John as you put it last year you
said it's a valentine's day for the rest
of love because you know we're obsessed
with romantic love and I get that I
understand but love is so much more than
that between parents and children and
siblings and friends it's the kind of
boring everyday love that ties the whole
world together so on this day we say I
love you to the people who we don't
normally say I love you too so I'm
asking take some time out of your day to
do that thing it's just it's a good
thing to do and if that's not enough for
you it's what Esther wants done I'll see
you on Tuesday
good morning John it's August 3rd 2013
and I love you is it it's 2014 yep